168 Russian athletes are competing under
a neutral flag at the Winter Olympics
this year
Russia's official representation is
banned at the Pyeongchang games because
of a large-scale doping scandal so its
competitors are formally titled Olympic
athlete from Russia the developer of the
Russian doping program dr. Grigory rota
Sheng cough spoke with Scott Pelley for
Sunday 60 minutes to discuss how
cheating still plagues the games he fled
to the u.s. in 2015 with files on that
program do you believe the Olympics can
ever be clean you could believe but in
fact it's it's a human nature
it's our sins it has nothing to do with
sports but there are 10 percent or 15
percent of people who are encouraging us
you can do nothing
there are cheaters but they're nature's
incorrigible 15 percent how many
countries are doping 20 plus 20 plus
social Grigory Rodchenko was a cheater
by nature and incorrigible to use his
word his recipes for banned drugs are
now well known among competitors and are
likely to outlive him so now it's a big
big problem and I'm sorry to creating
such problem because of my experience
and knowledge you are sorry that you
created this yes because now it's
effective in the working end it's not my
contribution to fight against doping
absolutely not
well you can see Scott Pelley is full
report Sunday night on 60 minutes at 7 6
central right here on CBS